la télévision fabrique de loudes
fabrique de l'oubli
le cinéma tulu fabriquer des souvenirs
[Musique]
des pentes servir du noma jean luc
godard alors c'est l'ennemi numéro 1 du
cinéma est la preuve c'est que c'est la
télévision qui l'emploie à 100 d'areva
non mais je dois je déteste tout ne
mange pas le cinéma lumière n'a pas
inventé le zoom enfin il a tout inventé
socle commun on peut dire qu'ils ont tué
langlois ils ont tué trucs faux ils ont
tué romy-schneider utilise aussi de lui
dire la télévision les journalistes
il est honteux pour pouvoir les enterrer
avec des belles phrases j'ai plein de
choses à vous dire si j'avais pu non
peut pas la télévision ne s'est pas fait
pour communiquer c'est fait pour
transmettre des ordres bond par rapport
à l'athénée si vous voulez bon j'ai le
sentiment d'être dans un pays occupé mon
pays c'est l'imaginaire et je suis dans
un pays qui est occupé par des gens que
l'imaginaire je crois pas d'intérêt ce
passe en même temps ce quelle agréable
c'est l'escroquerie financière
absolument fantastique que ça ça je
pense que c'est que c'est fait puisque
vous remplissez la facilement trois
heures d'antenne avec trois personnes
gratuit qui viennent pour leur propre
plaisir à leurs propres raisons la télé
n'a pas de projet elle un projet du
pouvoir et les gens qui travaillent
qu'ils le veuillent ou non sont des
employés d'un certain pouvoir et d'un
certain statut mais les téléspectateurs
sont d'accord puisque c'est eux qui
financent ah oui mais non mais
j'aimerais mieux parler avec vineuse
parce que
qu'on pense à revenir parce que sinon
moi je vais dire tellement de mal de
vous ça vaut pas la peine
oui puis ce serait grave absolument ça
serait gratuit comme vous quand je vois
la télévision que ça sera un directeur
de chaîne ou un cadreur mais je pense
pas qu'il a besoin
il a besoin de son salaire mais je pense
pas que louis ou ou georges sais pas
comment vous appelez là derrière je
pense pas vous avez besoin de mon image
moi si je viens vous filmez j'en ai
besoin
merci merci novembre
[Musique]
alors là on les garde
c'est la guerre sur le godard la moins
film et du monde souhaiteriez si les
pets sur le lieu des combats dans trois
jours vous en parlerai plus comme le
niger mais l'a pour l'instant ce que je
peux dire je peux pas rien vous dire sur
les malouines parce que je suis et
l'expriment mois chef d'antenne 2 je ne
sais pas ce qui se passe mais d'abord je
ne suis pas chef d'antenne en premières
informations
deuxièmement je ne sais pas ce qui s'est
passé parce que oui car je n'ai pas vu
ce qui s'est passé aux malouines ça vous
convient s'avoue satisfait qu'à bien
merci pour lui nous avons demandé à jean
luc godard
si ce qu'il a retenu de l'actualité
rien du tout si on voyait à la
télévision plutôt que d'entendre qu'on
parlait moins qu'on voyait plus je pense
que je pourrais revenir mais comme on
fait que parler moi j'ai rien vu du tout
justement en tant que cinéaste alors
vous pensez que le nous journalistes des
divisions nous montrons tron et nous
montrons pas assez comprenait déjà ce
que vous voyez vous verrez si vous et
vous comprendrez après moi moi je parle
facilement parce que je veux bien
discuter pour rien dire vous mettrez
jamais là-dessus
[Musique]